(electronic music)
- Hey.
Did you eat my burrito?
- Oh I don't want to taco bout it.
- Why?
- I was hungry. I'll pay you back.
- That's not the point.
- Am I not entitled to nourishment?
- I mean I didn't deny you shelter
before you got your job.
- I was hungry.
- Yeah now you know how I felt.
- And why did you roll a sock up in it
and put it back?
- Well I didn't want you
to think like a rodent
had taken it or something.
That way you know it was me.
(TV playing)
(electronic music)
(phone ringing)
- Yo.
- [Voiceover] What the hell man.
- What?
- [Voiceover] You're eating my pizza.
- Where are you?
- I'm out getting froyo.
- How do you see me?
- I set up a camera.
- You just watch this while
you're out getting froyo?
- Yeah I'm a student
of the human condition.
- Don't set up a camera in our apartment!
- [Voiceover] Don't eat my pizza.
- Well I was totally gonna
replace it with socks.
- Multicam system yo.
I can still see you.
- Oh yeah. What am I doing now?
- Jerking off a ghost.
Screenshotted. Bye!
- Fuck you. Fuck you!
(electronic music)
Fuck you.
Oh my God.
I hope Bubbles is OK.
- Well genetically speaking
pugs are never officially OK.
- Smushed face and all.
- But he kills it on Instagram.
- To Bubbles!
- To Bubbles.
- Pasta should be ready any minute.
This is Preston, my roommate.
He promised he was going
to stay in his room.
- Hi Preston!
- Hasta la vista.
- You don't have to talk to him.
- I'm so impressed that you cook.
The last guy I dated didn't even know
how to microwave anything.
- It's just pasta.
The sauce is from a jar.
- At least it's not ketchup.
- Just a second. It should
be just about ready.
Do you like parmesan cheese on your pasta?
Goes great with the sauce.
- Whatever the chef recommends.
- Chef's getting some tonight.
- Huh?
- [Man] Nothing.
(electronic music)
- What?
It's a poor man's Bloody Mary.
I'll pay you back.
- I'm sorry we don't have any butter.
- It looks good.
- We'll go out next time.
(electronic music)
Preston what happened? Are you.
- That's kind of sweet.
- He texted me that the
apartment was on fire.
- He was trying to surprise you.
(classical music)
- I guess it is kind of sweet
in the most bizarre way possible.
Your chair madam.
Fruit drink?
Preston's right.
Lucky Charm marshmallows do
make a delicious dessert.
- I have something else in mind.
(electronic music)
- Son of a bitch.
- [Voiceover] Bro.
(electronic music)